a new superhero might be about to land
in the DC Universe but are fans feeling
terrific about this new addition or
terrible James Gunn continues to stir
speculation about the future of his DC
Universe having now tweeted a
captionless photo of the superhero Mr
terrific the character is well known to
comic book fans is a brilliant mind
capable of competing with Bruce Wayne's
skills of detection strategy and
Engineering he was a significant part of
DC Comics Universe wide Futures and
story arc during the New 52 era and
recently served as the primary
antagonist of Tom King's Black Label
Maxi series strange Adventures Black
Adam's Hawkman actor Aldous Hodge
recently told Games Radar that he'd like
to do a team-up film featuring both his
character and Mr terrific with his
brother Edwin Hodge reprising the role
from the 2021 film Injustice the
character has been voiced by numerous
actors over the years from Michael Beach
and Justice League Unlimited to comedian
Hannibal Burris in Justice League action
Saved by the Bell it's time to tee up
the character made his live-action debut
in the TV series Arrow played by Echo
Kellum
thing they aim themselves
guns photo comes from an early 2000s
issue of Justice Society of America
illustrated by legendary comic book
artist Alex Ross and it is sparked
countless casting theories from fans one
Twitter user suggested the good place
star William Jackson Harper an actor who
recently made superhero headlines after
his casting in Ant-Man quantumania led
to rumors that he would play the mcu's
Mr Fantastic put the peeps in the
chairman pot it makes it taste bad
coming off of the back of the final
season of Atlanta another Twitter user
wrote look Keith Stanfield please James
another user suggested Jonathan Majors
who recently made his MCU debut in Loki
and is set to play the franchise's next
big bad King the Conqueror
not a room
version of me was so
pure of heart meanwhile one Twitter user
suggested This Is Us actor Sterling K
brown brown recently starred in the film
honk for Jesus save your soul but it's
more widely known to superhero fans as
the brother of King t'chaka in 2018's
Black Panther gun has been relatively
open about his role as the new co-head
of the DC Universe seemingly eager to
reassure fans that their wishes will be
considered under his leadership still
the question of Mr terrific is a tricky
one while he's definitely a popular
character he's also a member of an
ensemble and that considered one of the
main characters in the DC Universe many
fans were excited about the potential
for more projects about the Justice
Society of America but some are
apprehensive about the idea of DC
jumping straight into a Mr terrific
project without establishing him in
another film one user suggested set up
the main characters then start working
on DC's large list of other characters
to add in all in all fans reaction to
guns post seems to be a mixture of
excitement that their favorite character
might be adapted for the screen and
concern that the filmmakers might screw
it up such as the life of a comic fan
[Music]